okay
[Music]
the winter season of anime is a few
weeks away and I just can't help it with
the number of amazing shows we're gonna
have that's why I took it upon myself to
come up with what I think are the most
anticipated shows in that season these
are the top 10 most anticipated anime
for winter 2023.
we begin with an original anime giant
beasts of ours
[Music]
oh
starting out with the classic of the
fantasy story the mythical world of
Swords magic and monsters giant beasts
of ours Tales of a land ravaged by the
conflict between humanity and beasts
called the kyoju using kyoju Parts
Humanity likewise fought back against
the merciless beasts the story revolves
around Jiro a hunter of said beasts a
chance meeting with Gumi sets forth the
wheels to his story one where he and his
friends set forth to uncover the truth
behind the world for those who love
vintage jrpgs and want to experience the
same Vibes without it being packaged in
the form of a commercialized issakai
this is the one for you probably the one
that can give you a dose of nostalgia
for the simpler days of old it's an
original anime so your guesses are as
good as mine when it comes to the twists
that the title has in store for us
[Music]
foreign next up is the return of Misfit
of Demon King Academy
Misfit of Demon King Academy is a show
that really stuck with me ever since
seeing it in 2020 I've always had a soft
spot for these magic school battle
series but Misfit really did have a
different approach completely embracing
the overpowered protagonist Trope and
taking it to the extreme what came out
was a show that's very attention
catching while also sneaking in some
great twists of its own that's why I'm
so excited for the second season arnos
has been all sorts of awesome since the
first episode and I really want more of
the necron sisters I haven't read much
of the novel so I do wonder what other
challenges await are Mighty arnos for
those up for a magic school anime that
doesn't take itself too seriously then
go check out the first season it's got
this unique approach that makes it
self-aware while maintaining some stakes
and that's a balance you don't see
attempted often in the genre
foreign
[Music]
it's been a while since we got one of
these and this time the subject matter
is good old poker the high card in the
title refers to a group of players who
were tasked to collect 52 playing cards
with the ability to bestow Supernatural
power upon their wielders it's something
our protagonist Finn finds out after
being scouted to join this exclusive
order after surviving a shootout over a
lucky card it's never an easy road to
collect or 52x playing cards however as
the group finds themselves in the
crosshairs of a rival faction who's who
fueled by revenge and desire the
strongest Clash of the car players is
about to begin
foreign
[Music]
who said they're done bringing back the
classics Trigon is next in line for the
treatment
[Music]
ah try again a classic much loved by
anime fans of the 90s along with shows
like Cowboy Bebop it's one of those
Western looking shows that really made a
mark in anime history while not as big
of an impact as the actual Legends and
pillars of 90s anime Trigun had quite a
large fan base that loved it for its
action comedy world and charismatic main
character now it's time for the current
generation of anime fans to witness the
story for themselves Trigon Stampede is
a retelling of the classic tale but with
the benefit of modern technology it
doesn't seem to be a sequel from the
trailer that came out as it delves quite
a bit into Vash and knives origin story
it's a reimagination of the old story
that hopes to recapture the charm and
made the 90s anime so beloved amongst
people like uh maybe say your dad or
your uncle with a Trigun Stampede will
be able to reignite Old fans and catch
the hearts of new ones remains to be
seen but that's just one of the many
reasons that I'm excited for it mark
your calendars January 2023 is the date
[Music]
foreign we then proceed with the angel
next door spoils me rotten tomato
ES
there's a saying that doing good gets
you rewarded somewhere down the line
amane gets more than what he bargained
for after he gets sick helping a girl
and lending his umbrella instead of just
getting his umbrella returned he gets
mahiru's help the only problem is that
his apartment is nothing short of
unsightly that's nothing for the
almighty mahiru who proceeds to not only
help him recover from the cold but to
also take care of him by doing chores
and hopefully getting his life back on
the right track it's a wholesome series
that never fails to bring a smile to my
face with how cute and Charming it is
it's also a simple story as a light
novel low self-esteem dude meets
seemingly perfect girl who opens his
Horizons as they grow close to one
another there's not a lot of
heavy-handed drama too so if you're up
for something sweet to consume and
unwind with this could be my
recommendation this upcoming season
Baka
you enjoying this list so far hit that
like button and subscribe it's one of
the best ways you can help the video do
well in the YouTube algorithm and help
the channel grow so I'd really
appreciate it it's a fourth season at
number five as we look at boom go stray
dogs
[Music]
stray dogs it's a gem of a series that
combines my love for battles core powers
and literary influences it feels like a
fake anime but covering literature
essentially making it The Best of Both
Worlds but even if you don't completely
get the references the exciting fights
and The Lovable characters will surely
keep you entertained for this season
we'll get to see the aftermath of the
cannibalism Arc and get to see our
agency go head to head with the hunting
dogs it's a fugitive Arc that I'm sure
fans will be stoked to finally see
animated the chase will take our cars
through even more tense confrontations
and shocking revelations and it's
something that you don't want to miss if
you're one of the people who haven't
heard of Boom go stray dogs yet then
this is your cue to start catching up
before the winter season arrives
[Music]
comes in in fourth place
If This Were a decade ago the thought of
a big mainstream video game being
adapted into anime would have had people
questioning it and I don't mean visual
novels like fate or Stein's gate those
were often decent to good but you know
what I'm talking about are you sure the
Final Fantasy stuff was all right but
lots of them were hit and miss science
isn't the case anymore and game
adaptations have been upping their game
recently that's why it's not surprising
that the next big title to join the
lineup of game adaptations is the fan
favorite Nia automata for half a decade
the franchise's thrilled Gamers
worldwide and introduce characters
who've become cultural icons this anime
looks to bring the magic to the
peripheral demographic anime fans who
just can't get enough of dystopian
Sci-Fi series people who've never played
the game but are curious as to what the
rage is all about you don't have to wait
any longer January is when we'll get to
see this anime adaptation of one of
square enix's big modern hits
roaring into third place for this list
is Black Clover sword of the wizard King
it's truly a joy to see how far black
clovers come in my previous videos I've
always compared Black Clover to an
underdog Shonen in real life from being
demeaned early on to slowly getting
stronger and earning the respect it
deserves it makes me happy to see it
even get in a movie so far we don't have
much information about the movie in his
plot but one thing is for certain it's
gonna look stunning Black Clover towards
the end of its run or even halfway
through already gave us some Banger
fights with breathtaking visuals and
twists it may not be too unique in the
world of Shonen but in terms of what
you'd want out of Shonen like the fights
and badass moments it's got a hell of a
resume for it whether this movie will be
a completely anime original thing or
something that will incorporate elements
of the manga that never made it to the
anime I mean it doesn't matter all I
know is that if you're a Black Clover
fan this is one film that you've gotta
watch
in second place is Tokyo Revengers
Christmas Showdown
how fitting that winter sees the next
part of one of the big hits of modern
mainstream anime Tokyo Revengers has
quickly become a household name and
that's owing to many things the action
the Intriguing premise and especially
the charismatic characters who found
their fair share of fangirls and Fanboys
while the first season had given us some
epic moments it can't just end there now
can it that's why it's a no-brainer for
Tokyo Avengers to get a sequel
chronicling the Darwin's next foray a No
Holds Barred clash with the black dragon
and the Sheba family it's finally
draken's time to shine in this high
stakes conflict the fans won't want to
miss take your Avengers returns with
this new arc in January
oh they know
top of this list is Finland Saga
[Music]
what several people have been calling
2019's anime of the year is getting a
much awaited sequel Finland Saga has
been an enjoyable ride through one of
the less famous periods in historical
Europe season one brought the action the
adventure the drama and everything you
like from an epic like this normally I'd
say that season two would be looking to
bring more of the same but for Finland
Saga it's the opposite sure the change
of pace and the shift in focus to
another aspect of this period might
catch people off guard but I feel it's
one of the strengths of Finland Saga it
can shift gears to a slower more
methodical and examining Pace as it
gives us more comprehensive views of the
Viking era people have been looking
forward to Finland Saga and all I can
say is that you should prepare to be
surprised and that's it for this list
how does your ranking look make sure to
share with me through the comment
section you can also check in on our
multiple social media Outlets all links
will be provided in the description box
thanks for watching the video and I'll
see you next time more or less coming
your way only on videotube
[Music]